hey guys welcome back to your weekly
dead stream recap and today was a very
informational devastating so let's get
right into it let's not waste any time
so the first thing on the list is that
there's going to be a new patch that
rolls out soon and this patch will
include multiple things one including a
quick penalty system which means if
players leave enough matches in a row or
at all they'll be probably they're
probably going to receive a suspension
from playing or for a couple days or
maybe an entire season if they do it too
many times you've yourself could also do
a blizzard does for overwatch and give
players in XP reduction for a certain
amount of matches until those matches
are completed but these are just my
ideas no clue they're going to be
implemented or not but hopefully they
will the next patch is also going to
include a fix for player versus AI
matches not giving awards the end of the
games I have yet to experience this
though but if any of you have put them
in the comments below also for any other
colorblind players out there there will
be the first stages of a colorblind mode
added to the game I am not colorblind so
I won't be able to tell if it works but
when this patch does come out I would
like you to tell me in the comments if
this does work or not if it doesn't no
gladly talk to the devs myself they
probably won't listen but I will be sure
to tell them that there are certain
types of colorblindness that still do
not work the next thing on the list is
the reflex guard bug from Alex Wizards
on reddit has been acknowledged by the
devs and it will be fixed if you don't
know what this is I'll put a video on
screen for you but basically this is a
problem that occasionally happens to all
the assassins including shinobi but when
they try to - or attack in a certain
guard stance
the games which isn't making that player
not able to attack or defend in that
direction but thankfully they didn't say
that they acknowledged it and it will be
fixed soon the next thing on the list is
some pretty sad news for us console
players we will we will not be receiving
60fps on console for for honor sadly
because of console limitations that's
pretty sad to hear for us next on the
list is the devs have also acknowledged
the Centurion kick spam and are planning
on making it so that there's no stun
lock when hit by the attack this is nice
and all but I thought the whole point of
the attack was for him to have an opener
to use so it having not it the attack
and having a stun lock may be a bit
difficult for him to open up opponents
and the fact that they're worried about
his kick when they have to
have yet to even look at Shinobi's cake
is kind of crazy anyway
tell me the comments below guys what you
think about this in the comments I would
gladly I would love to hear your opinion
on this
staying on the topic of characters Roman
one of the devs said there they're
looking at the fix for warlords ability
to carry people around the map causing
them to lose all of their stamina I put
up a video explaining I'll put up a
video explaining what this means and
honestly I'm all for this patch it's not
even fighting really it's just this
warlord carrying this helpless wall
burner across the map while he basically
loses stamina and can't do anything
because if it being unblockable and him
being knocked on the gun not be able to
dodge it in time so I'm very glad that
this patch is going to be coming out
soon next on the list is that the
deficit stated that they haven't really
gotten enough Orochi feedback to
determine what needs to be buffed
exactly with him so they're going to be
starting a bunch of threads up on Reddit
to get some feedback from suni Orochi
players out there or any people that
just like a roach in general and want
him to be buffed I advise you to go on
reddit in the next couple days check out
the threads and kind of share your own
feedback with the DES on that next up is
that the event playlist that was dropped
today or a couple days ago for the at
the beginning of season two they're
going to be making more of those in the
future and they'll probably be the same
as the one we have now I didn't really
explain why but they will probably be
adding more events for us to play in the
future the next thing on the list is
that there's going to be no weekly
content for today and to talk about the
executions that effects that we talked
about a week ago they are confirmed but
they aren't fully complete so no details
on a release and the yellow indicator
that shows up the gear even though it's
there it shows up for the new gear but
yet you still have it and it's not new
is being patched so thank goodness for
this did the amount of gear I have for
all the heroes in the game bro and the
amount of gear that still shows up is
new when I've looked at it over eight
times
it's insane so thankfully they are going
to patch this and make me not lose my
insanity and lastly for today the devs
are saying ranked is coming better
ranked is coming soon but there is no
official date in my opinion I still
don't think foreigners really ready for
rank yet with all the disconnects and
the fact that rank is going to be filled
with people using only the top five
characters which isn't going to make mid
to top level ranked play enjoyable and
probably
causing people to stop playing ranked or
the game entirely anyway I hope you all
did enjoyed today's video and if you did
hit the like button if you're new to
this channel and you've never heard of
me if you've never heard of me before it
hit the subscribe button and then also
hit the bell icon right next to it to
never miss an upload and if you missed
my last video there's an annotation on
the top right and in that video we
talked about the leaked emotes for all
the characters including shinobi and
Centurion so you don't want to miss out
on that but anyway guys have a great
rest of your day and peace out